ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to another exciting episode of
shimcast IRL I am Seamus Coughlin
filling in for Tim Poole who is on a
coming-of-age journey in theaters this
November in tonight's news a California
school district is going to have to pay
three million dollars for rejecting an
lgbtq curriculum covering Harvey Milk
the Stanford dean of Dei resigns after
supporting and encouraging a unruly
student protest and Congressman Gates
introduces legislation to prohibit
funding for the Department of Justice
for being used for special counsel Jack
Smith's probe into Donald Trump we're
going to get into all of that in more
but first hit that like button and if
you want to support what we're doing
here become a member at timcast.com so
you can see our after hours show the
uncensored version where we're able to
say some of the things that we can't say
on YouTube but would like to also if you
want to help support us in building
culture and keeping the lights on go
over to castbrew.com and pick yourself
up a bag of fast Brew Coffee we're
building culture we're sponsoring
ourselves so head on over there and get
yourself a bag we are joined today by
Daniel Turner a founder and executive
director of power of the future Daniel
thank you for coming back onto the show
it is great to be on the show thank you
and I got a quick story for y'all yes
please do intros and I'll be brief a
friend of the show who watches it a guy
named Trevor uh I do oil and gas and
fossil fuel advocacy issues energy job I
battle the green groups for a living a
friend of the show Trevor is from a
small town called Greeley Nebraska
population around 500 and as the bite
Administration is dumping out billions
and billions of dollars hundreds of
billions of dollars for wind and solar
the small town in Greeley Nebraska
suddenly was told they're going to get
this enormous Wind Farm they wanted many
of the residents to sign 75-year leases
75 years to turn over their land so that
they could put up these wind farms and
Trevor a friend of the show was like
something doesn't feel right and saw me
on an episode and said we're doing a
town hall but we can't find people able
to talk about the other side of the
issue would you come so I flew to
Greeley Nebraska didn't do any
fundraising wasn't trying to become
famous this is about them in their town
and it was around three and a half hours
of a town hall where I sat down with the
residents and just talked about what are
wind turbines what does it do what is
this company going to do the funny thing
is the company building the wind farm
was there but they refused to engage
they refused to talk about it so when
questions came up like hey this is
tornado country the tornado comes
through and blows up this wind turbine
and projectiles go in every direction
and it goes through your house or your
barn
who cleans up right who's liable for
that these wind turbines right they're
moving pieces they have thousands of
gallons of fluid if that fluid leaks who
cleans up are you responsible or is the
wind farm what's the environmental
impact study I tell you if we're going
to drill for oil and gas the amount of
third-party environmental impact studies
we have to do is is astronomical they
got Exempted from environmental impact
studies so I'm saying look I'm not
telling you to vote against the wind
farm I'm just saying these are really
good questions that you should get
answers to before you sign over
grandpa's farm for 75 years and so end
it very quickly with this this audience
is getting engaged right people on uh
you can call it the right conservative
anti-establishment everyone frame it
people are a little tired of getting
things shoved down their throat whether
it's covered whether it's green whether
it's trans and to see this level of
Engagement that a member of this
audience reached out and said you know
you're an expert come help us out I hope
more people do and I'm looking at the
camera if your Town's going through this
with solar with wind if someone's coming
in saying we're going to take over your
land for our agenda and you're nervous
you know find me on Twitter and or DM me
or find me daily powerthefuture.com so I
just want to thank this show I want to
thank all of you because you're all part
of it and I want to thank Tim for
putting it together because when people
like that like you Trevor buddy when
people like that get involved we will
stop all the bad nonsense that's
happening in society like you said
taking over culture taking over taking
our rights back so thank you for the
quick shout out thank you to the folks
in Greeley and thanks to this program
and great to be on yeah and again it's
great to have you back on and it's
always very encouraging to hear that
there are audience members who are
taking this very seriously and getting
involved and trying to uh instantiate
some change at the local level that's
that's really uh important that's really
important yeah it's amazing it's awesome
that you took the time to get out there
and I appreciate that you're willing to
respond to your Twitter EMS and fly to
Nebraska and help out because that is
kind of crazy that a company wanting to
put wind turbines on your land just
declines to talk to you not the start of
a great relationship in my opinion no
and there's so much money in the
inflation reduction Act and the
infrastructure bill that this is going
to happen more and more and and what's
what does it do to the environment what
does it do to cattle what does it do to
aquifers again I'm not saying all these
things should stop happening obviously
I'm not in favor of wind and solar I
think they're useless products
um but just ask hard questions and heck
right before we went live we were having
a hard conversation we agree yeah on on
like a lot of trans issues ask hard
questions I Just Want To Have and when
you try to shut down I know we're going
to get to shutting down debate but when
you try to shut down debate and
conversation boy that should make people
very nervous anyone who doesn't want to
answer questions and says stop asking
them like you know where that person
stands right yeah so you definitely do
well yeah we've got some stories about
that tonight too yeah so thanks folks
yeah so I'm so glad you're here I'm
Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com I'm so happy to be back on
another episode of shimcast
no shame is doing a great job he
deserves a lot of credit this is a lot
of work thank you yeah I'm ready for
gymcast.com I'm so glad to be here with
our favorite music producer what's up
everyone I'm Carter Banks I do all
things music here at timcast and I'm
filling in for Ian tonight who is on a
mission to find where Tim is we wish you
the best of luck yeah he's uh he's out
there looking he's very loyal and I
admire that it's been a hard week for
him you know it has been yeah and serge
is here uh yeah I'm here I also produce
music
he does oh man I don't realize how
political I made this episode
my my favorite music producer who's
produced who was employed by the company
I'm employed by hey I mean I'm not
employed to do music so you guys know I
also produce music
yourself everything I do not produce
music I also don't produce to be honest
I also don't produce music but you are a
journalist so I am a journalist yeah
there's great music in your in your uh
we have parody songs yeah they're
awesome I take it back please help me
help you what what show's already off
the rails I've been asked to do music
like your music before it's 8-bit kind
of video game type music it's very cool
nice nice yeah well you're doing awesome
stuff here with Tim thank you sir I
think so well speaking of things that
aren't so awesome uh California School
is gonna have to pay over three million
dollars after rejecting an lgbtq
curriculum the curriculum uh covered
Harvey Milk who is the first uh openly
gay elected official in the United
States who is assassinated in 1978
here's the thing about Harvey Milk he
was known to have been preying on
underage boys he was in a quote unquote
relationship with a 16 year old at one
point when he was in his 30s but of
course children have to learn about him
in school as if he's a hero and this
District the school board said no sorry
we're not interested in teaching our
kids that so Newsome said we're going to
find you 1.5 million dollars and force
you to pay another 1.6 million in
shipping costs associated with the
material that were sent to these schools
so we're seeing stories like this all
the time I'm glad to see that the school
board is fighting back look at uh
Newsome who claims to be the gatekeeper
and the warrior for free speech when
he's talking about book bands and the
fact that all ideas need to be allowed
in California telling people that they
actually have to have this curriculum
forced on them when their school board
has said no we don't want this there's a
hill you have to die on and eventually
um otherwise you keep losing and and I
think again it's hard it's easy for me
to say this because it's not my school
or it's not my my three million dollars
but the answer is no
yeah we're just not going to pay that
fine and we're not going to teach it and
are you going to extort three million
dollars from us are you going to are you
going to shut down the school well then
you know what you shut down the school
sorry like eventually you just have to
stop giving in to this because uh if
school boards what's the purpose of
having a school board if then the
governor can just override it and then
the governor is overridden by the
Department of Education and where does
it end so ultimately it's really just
Joe Biden Joe Biden decides everything
that's absolutely right well I mean
these these people are all tyrannical
and it's so frustrating because you you
had Obama come out the other day and
write this letter saying oh it's wrong
to buy on books and of course the books
that are being banned here are generally
pornographic they contain materials that
are scarring for children and it's the
parents who are saying we don't want our
children to see this content the vast
majority of these quote unquote book
bands are led by parental groups and
even opponents of that will acknowledge
this but they'll say these are parents
who are backwards religious
fundamentalists even though firstly as
far as I'm aware I don't know that
there's actually a strong religious
component to it I would imagine there is
just sense that we're in a country which
is based on Christian values but these
people I know some of the people who go
up and fight these school boards and
they're not all religious people by any
means so the left will try to smear
these people to try to smear the
Grassroots efforts to get this
pornographic content out of schools and
the truth is it's because they know
that's the only option they can't try to
blame the the usual actors the big
donors any corrupt political class for
this they can tell this is coming from
parents this is coming from families who
are saying stop preying upon our
children and I think you'll see these
tests uh going forward this idea that
you don't want this type of curriculum
in your school for what seems to be
legitimate reasons and so you will have
to pay a fine so you feel guilty and so
you don't feel like maybe we shouldn't
do that it's going to hurt our kids
education these tests are going to be
something that parents unfortunately
face a lot it reminds me a little bit of
this story about the school district in
Utah a liberal parent said well you I I
think you should ban the Bible because
the Bible talks about sex and the
Bible's pornographic scenes but it
doesn't and one
lawmakers who had been really pushing to
keep lgbtq curriculum uh and again I
should say sexually explicit uh
curriculum out of school said well if
this is the price we have to pay that's
okay because I would rather uh make sure
that your kids are protected even if
that means they have to learn about the
Bible at home and I find it interesting
that we're coming up against these tests
pretty regularly right now if we have to
keep something out what are we willing
to do for that I think a great tactic
that I've seen a lot of parents do is
they try to go to the school board
meetings and they try to read the book
out loud yes and they're stopped I think
DeSantis did it at a press conference
and all the networks how to go to
commercial break yeah and that's that's
just the most valuable time if I can't
say this to you and we're all adults
here if I said these things right now
YouTube would would find Tim I mean it
wouldn't find me so I guess I could go
ahead and say them right I can drop the
F-bomb it's not my show yeah
and Tim's not here so he's not here who
cares but I think that's such a valuable
tactic like show how vile these things
are and then and then stop hiding behind
gay people to do it stop it's it's
pornography don't hide it's it's it's
it's it's either it's sexual
exploitation of children stop using gay
people as your Shield because you're a
bunch of perverts that's quite frankly I
gotta say the book we have right here I
opened it to a random page and just the
first thing I saw was like
I can't even describe it it was
disgusting it's Vision it's it's really
disgusting and so genderqueer is one
example of this the other example we've
brought up because we actually have the
book here is this book is gay and this
is a book that is in schools and school
libraries and it actually explains how
to sign up for gay hookup apps now
here's the thing it does say oh these
apps are for adults but hold on a second
this stuff the way Smartphones work with
their interface it's not rocket science
adults can figure it out why is there a
guide on how to sign up for these apps
in schools where miners can check them
out you don't put something in a book
that a miner shouldn't know and then
write if you're under 18 don't read past
this point or this section isn't for you
and that's not how this works yeah yeah
exactly don't do it we're just gonna put
it here and let you make your own
decisions I think that's the craziest
thing that the you know the argument
that comes up and that I hear pretty
frequently is you know uh people need to
hear these things because it's we need
to have a sex positive culture and we
need to have a culture that uh you know
these issues are life and death for some
people because if you don't know you
don't feel firm this that and the other
then uh you know you're in danger of all
kinds of terrible things and of course
we want to live in a compassionate
Society but does that mean miners need
to read sexually explicit content in
schools no it doesn't well no but here's
the thing they say we want a sex
positive Society what does that mean
what does it mean what does sex positive
mean they're trying to negate the
purpose of sex by spreading perversion
by definition they are sex negative the
purpose of sex is unity and procreation
if you're trying to strip that away from
it you are negating you are sex negative
what they're really trying to say is we
want to spread perversion that's all
that's all I think we're sexualized
enough to society yeah yeah I mean
you can't watch any commercial without a
beat you can't watch any music video
minus a couple of country ones
you really can't watch much without it
being about sex exactly how much of a
pervert do you have to be to complain
about the fact that there's not enough
of it out there all the time and and
should we be telling teenagers your
sexual identity is the biggest thing you
should know and identify and think about
all the time right isn't there enough
pressure as an as a young adult to come
of age and to to Grapple with difficult
life problems like do we need to say
your libraries need to be stocked with
this or you're thinking about all the
time when really we should be
encouraging them to pursue do their
intellectual passions to develop good
moral character right like there is no
reason that this should be the number
one conversation you have with your
teens no matter how you think their
their orientation will end up especially
when you consider and I hate saying this
because I I don't like to knock America
I I love this country and I love the
people in this country but I will say it
bluntly especially when you realize how
ignorant our young people are oh yeah
you can say poorly educated and they are
you could just flat out and say dumb
um like these are subjects that a we
shouldn't Broach them ever but if if all
of our kids had Straight A's in the then
the school board was like well should we
start thinking about other things but
our kids are incredibly dumb yes like
they basically but you see the numbers
30 35 don't read it leveled can perform
math at level like most of them can't
write or read script so you you scratch
your head and say well we want our young
people to be sex positive it's like I
just like them to be literate first like
can we just do the basics right yeah
exactly and any adult who like tells you
they have this agenda like oh yeah I
want this child to be really accepting
of a lot of different sexual things like
okay why because I've said this before
on the show but we asked this question
as conservatives why do kids need to see
that that's the wrong question the
question is why do you need to show that
to a kid why are you so invested in
ensuring that a kid sees that I think we
all know no kid likes to read about sex
until there are a certain age and it's I
don't care if it's hetero homo it
doesn't matter like like they're
introducing it to children at an age
that it's so uncomfortable and it should
be uncomfortable it's healthy like a
nine-year-old should not be a sexual
being and when they say well everyone is
a sexual being if you think a
nine-year-old is a sexual being you are
a pedophile you belong in jail yeah
absolutely yeah and you know it's
different when you're talking about
especially guys you know and they're
they're hitting their hormones and they
would read any book that's well maybe
not those yes they'd be more interested
in sex books and sex talks but but the
fact that we're doing this with
six-year-old and seven-year-old is just
so disgusting I would agree well evil I
just want to mention one thing quickly
even with what you're saying like when
when kids go through puberty and they
start noticing the opposite sex you're
right that they have an interest there
but that's also why you need to be even
more protective at that point and ensure
that they don't end up seeing disgusting
things that are going to pervert them
because they'll end up going see and
seeking out material and there's so much
perversion online that they'll stumble
into the solution isn't like well let's
show them the weirdest grossest stuff we
can find the solution is educate them on
the dangers of looking at pornography
talk to them about the fact that
researchers are discovering a strong
link between uh pornography and
impotence you tell you you tell young
men that I promise you that's going to
alter their behavior right people need
to be protected from these things these
things shouldn't be forced onto them but
again I think we're all pretty clear on
what the agenda is here we know why
there's an interest on the part of so
many people in this system to get miners
invested in this perverse content and it
it's telling that the reason this school
board rejected this content that
California is trying to force on them is
because it was covering uh the first
elected gay politician in the country
who celebrated by the left and viewed as
a martyr and who was exploiting and
preying upon and abusing underage boys
had had a 16 year old quote-unquote
boyfriend when he was in his 30s that's
not a boyfriend it's a minor he groomed
I haven't seen said chapter I'd love to
know what the chapter was because that's
what they're saying like this was a book
that was explaining that Harvey Milk was
killed in 19 whatever Europe
um but I guarantee you it was not that
you know and if you had a chapter of the
70s for 14 15 16 year old kids and you
talked about unrested in the 70s famous
people who were assassinated you can go
through the list you can throw his name
down because he was famous and he was
assassinated but I would love to see the
actual chapter
saying about his life because I
guarantee it was not that innocuous like
we just mentioned that he was a gay
politician who was killed I'm like oh no
you didn't yeah no no you didn't
movie with Sean Penn in it yeah I don't
think they mentioned any of that oh
there's a lot they'll fail to mention in
these different biopics they do about
these perverse figures they celebrate if
you think Hollywood would believe no
wait a minute no I know well I've
mentioned before that there was a film
produced about Alfred Kinsey where Liam
Neeson played him Alfred Kinsey the
person yes oh my God yes Liam Neeson
played Alfred Kinsey in a film where
they celebrate him as this heroic heroic
like self-sacrificing Saint scientist
and you know he was just interested in
studying sex in this puritanical Society
of course what they leave out with the
fact is that he was complicit in the the
sexual abuse of literally hundreds of
underage boys including infants uh they
don't mention the fact that in his
published work he said things that uh
supported and endorsed pedophilia by
saying that when a child is abused what
really traumatizes them as their parents
in his words overreaction to it as if as
if you can overreact to something so
horrible
um it's it's disgusting they celebrate
disgusting things it's great to see this
school board uh pushing back it's kind
of like when the left talks about
Margaret Sanger and they forget that to
mention that her purpose in starting
this organization was to eradicate black
people yep yeah and it's like well we
just talk about it for women's rights
it's like do you want the full story or
not the full story there was a video
that I'm pretty sure Lena Dunham uh
narrated and it was like here's the
history on planned Heritage and they got
to the point about Eugenics and she's
like she was kind of involved in
Eugenics but we're just gonna ignore
that he would be like what are you
talking about this is crazy easy and I
mean that's just the the mission though
if they can scrub enough of history and
make it easier to digest through movies
then you will learn to ignore these
things in fact you will forget them and
I think that's one of the best parts
about this is not only is it a local
community really advocating for what
they want and what their values are but
also saying like we aren't going to
overlook this person's sorted past
because you guys have refashioned him as
a hero yeah absolutely and speaking with
the problems that exist within modern
education Stanford laws Equity Dean is
booted out after uh stoking woke
students rude protest at a conservative
judge who's invited to give a talk so a
Stanford Dean who was slammed for
letting students tackle a conservative
federal judge before berating him
herself has left her role basically what
happened was this judge came to speak on
campus the students protested he went to
uh basically explain that it was
unacceptable that it was impossible to
hear him because he was being spoken
over and she went on to uh berate him so
she has decided that she's going to be
leaving her role as assistant Dean for
diversity equity and inclusion what are
they going to do without her at Stanford
law school to pursue another opportunity
the law school said in an email to its
students Thursday what do you guys think
about this story do you think that they
have more Dei coordinators at that
school do you think she was the only one
do you think Stanford has a couple well
I don't know if you know this but there
is a notorious shortage of Dei
Professionals in this country we
actually might run out of them which is
very frightening it is scary because who
who keeps the country running
how do we get keep any of this going
without them I mean there are so many
things to critique about the story first
off uh let's let's be glad to see the
end of administrative blow in in
universities uh famously that's that's
terrible for any any function University
this particular story just makes me
laugh or talking about a little bit
beforehand uh but the fact that you know
this this event was it was on March 9th
and this uh Trump appointed federal
judge Kyle Duncan came to speak he was
invited there by the federal Society uh
he gets shouted down he asked us for an
administrator she comes in and is
berating him saying that you know he's
hurtful and he's tearing this Society
Community apart disenfranchising student
rights right but then afterwards I hate
this in French but then afterwards a
couple students for the wrote for the
Stanford uh review saying she sent out
an email beforehand engineering chaos
she came in with prepared remarks they
call I really appreciate this from the
students they called Cinderella said you
say you value Free Speech then you need
to hold this person accountable because
she intentionally went against it now of
course this battle continued to be
public uh and uh Steinbach the woman
involved wrote her own op-ed that the
Wall Street Journal published being like
I was just there to de-escalate of
course I don't know what happened but it
could not have been that I was at all
inciting this uh and so you get these
conflicting accounts and I find this
deeply interesting she said that she was
there to represent the student voices so
they could stop shouting which means
that like she came in with it and
started shouting yeah well well firstly
of course she was just trying to calm
things down that's what a Dei officer
does as a University at a university
providing people by their identity at
all also I love this excuse I love this
excuse this is golden this is like such
an incredible attempt at spin I almost
admire it when all the students were
heckling this person and I went up there
and began heckling them it's because I
was trying to stop the students from
doing it I was trying to give them an
outlet this is what I have begun to call
Outlet Theory basically what left-wing
people will try to do to justify the
normalization of bad behavior is they'll
say this bad thing is going to happen
anyway so we need to give it an outlet
and of course what you end up doing is
encouraging it to continue to happen and
you get more of it and I think it's not
surprising that this is the excuse you
went with because it actually fits into
the framework of a left-wing worldview
and the excuses they usually make no no
the only reason I was doing bad thing is
because I wanted to give bad thing an
outlet because I'm actually against that
thing on some level it's totally
incoherent well it's funny that she's
diversity and inclusion and she seemed
to lack both of those as her role right
I mean there was no diversity in terms
of intellectual diversity and what about
inclusion you know whatever happened
it's funny how you know when I was a kid
they would say well if you don't like it
turn off the channel or if you don't
like it don't listen to that album and
now it's the right saying that if you
don't want to go listen to this judge
just don't go to the lecture that is not
allowed a surprise in a class that you
had to be in right this was an event
organized by Society for him to come to
that everyone probably knew it was going
to be this guy which is what made them
want to go there right and I'm not
against the concept of protesting it
just makes me crazy that the idea is
that this person had to be completely
shouted down rather than this
institution supposed to be about
learning and growth and having your
ideas challenged and this is
manufactured protesting because yeah
we're all pretty smart but the exception
of this one name another judge
right like name another not Supreme
Court I can name them name a federal
judge I bet you none of us really could
so what college student is like you're
telling me judge Duncan Kyle is no like
this isn't a name that is like it's
hilarious it's all manufactured because
he was appointed by Trump
and I will say especially when you're in
college like who's actually reading
Flyers you know like I certainly wasn't
them or going to this someone
manufactured this crisis and got all the
kids whipped up and now the kids are all
in a frenzy which is sad how much of
lemming the college students can become
so it's interesting then that of course
the students point out that Steinbach
this this Dei administrator sent out an
email about this event it's almost like
maybe she was interested in there being
a protest so she could have a nice Bible
come down yeah
well I will say I I think what's what I
found the most interesting about the
story because this played out over a
couple months is that uh at least two
federal judges said we're adding
Stanford to our no hire list we will not
take clerks from Stanford law which
means that every student at Stanford is
affected by this of course they assume
they're conservative out there at
Stanford law I hope you're doing well uh
but it comes in the heels of a different
similar event at Yale law school so
there are now a stack of law schools
that there are Judges and I think this
is great they're saying I will not hire
from your school I do not like your
school and your student bodies uh stance
on free speech and diversity and I do
not like the way you're treating
conservatives that's unacceptable to me
you would not you would not be a good
fit for my office and again
I think these these small changes this
school district taking a stance these
judges saying like we won't tolerate it
of course some people suffer in the
crosshairs I'm sure the young
conservatives yeah and Stamper are like
well dang man yeah but on the other hand
good for the judges for doing something
and not sitting around being like well
we can't get involved yes you know this
that meal push back if they're going to
try to use their leverage against you to
undermine Civil Society you got to push
back Daniel you mentioned something
earlier how the left always used to say
if you don't like it you can change the
channel and how they're hypocritical for
not sticking to that but I think what
you're missing is what they were saying
is if you don't like it you can change
the channel those are the options that
you have when I don't like it you change
the channel yeah it's always been about
dominance right evil calls for tolerance
until it's in charge and then it demands
your submission yeah remember when the
riots were happening in the Summer of
Love And even you can go back further
even in the the Trump inauguration of
2017 to go off your point Sheamus when a
lot of Mayors said look we're just
giving them space to protest and you're
like well you're letting them Burn the
City down we're just giving them space
to protest and that's what this was that
was what this diversity the EI
coordinator was saying I am just giving
them a platform to express their ideas
and I partook of it because I wanted to
try to control the violence and again if
you give people a space to do if you
give bad people a space to commit bad
acts they will commit bad acts well and
this is part of what's so uh hilarious
just about how quickly they expose
themselves as complete and total
unprincipled Hypocrites I remember
during the 2020 riots there were two
things I kept hearing from left-wing
individuals
first thing rioting is the language of
the unheard yes okay so that's one quote
let's all just keep it that's beautiful
yeah isn't that thank you doesn't that
just touch your heart poetry and then
there was a second point that they kept
making repeatedly I saw this all over
Twitter I saw left-wing people I knew
saying this they were going well you
know conservatives claim the point of
you know 2A is to like fight back
against tyranny and why aren't they
helping us as we are here trying to
fight back against tyranny
so literally by the way calling for
Insurrection right and then just a few
months later on January 6th when we had
conservatives rioting well all of a
sudden the response was to make sure
they were as unheard as possible
social media banned Donald Trump ban
Donald Trump the sitting president of
the United States from one of the
largest communication Platforms in the
world you're gonna tell me you thought
writing was the language of the unheard
and the way you get rioting is by
silencing people and then you silenced
the person you believe
exactly who you believe is the
figurehead in in the voice of the people
who were rioting and then all of a
sudden Insurrection became a bad thing
that we weren't supposed to be in favor
of and weren't supposed to tolerate and
we're supposed to be very against
meanwhile just a few months ago on May
29th of 2021 left-wing radicals
surrounded the White House broke down
the barrier forced the president of the
United States and his family into the
presidential bunker in the entire media
laughed about it and said it was so mean
that Donald Trump cleared those
protesters out of there before before
they tried to burn down Saint John's
well you're forgetting the most
important verse in uh the modern
religion which is uh it's okay when we
do it progressives 23 16. yeah that's
right that's exactly right you don't
understand yes
because we are on a moral High Ground
right so when we say these people are
writing because they're unheard we are
correct and when we're saying you guys
are riding because you're evil and the
devil we are also right there's no
arguing there because there's no
consistent logic there's no consistent
application of values yeah it's funny
that this this decision came out today
when there was that house hearing on on
censorship and and I'm glad there's
hearings on censorship there has to be
more of a conversation about it
especially when you're in the college
level right if you are if you're
encouraging this type of behavior on
what is supposed to be an academic
environment to look at all ideas and and
discover knowledge Etc you're you're
doing your your students a great
Injustice and college kids are young
they may not be minors right there most
of them are 18 and older so they are
legal adults but they are very young and
very impressed and what it's a travesty
to see well it's falling off the early
conversation right we're teaching our
young children to be perverts and we're
teaching our College children to be dumb
and close-minded and and it's it's
tragic because you have now a growing uh
Society of just dumb perverts well yes
no yes thank you could have said it
better myself and what I'll also add is
that the two go hand in hand right I
think a huge part of why they they want
to erode these children's sense of
identity and pervert them is one because
again they want to reproduce themselves
in some sense they want to make other
people's children uh into perverts but
on top of that if you get a person
completely inward focused with their
proclivities and their sexual Tendencies
it actually dulls their intellect and
they're less interested in learning
about the world and other people and
they become a lot less critical because
they have to spend their life trying to
justify something irrational so they
don't become well practiced in applying
rational principles to their life and so
they become less interested in seeing
the truth I'm not saying that everyone
who does anything bad ever is going to
be completely unable to see any truth
I'm just saying that these kinds of
actions make it more difficult for a
person to see reality I think when you
encourage anyone to be a narcissist you
you dull their senses to do anything
else right and if you tell people that
smoking weed is the most important thing
you could do or any other aspect if you
encourage narcissism in young people and
you make learning well look at the
subject you know the line that's very
common now is you know your truth
um your truth what is your truth and and
so if if that becomes your your your
your compass uh then then yeah your
senses are dull to any other objective
learning or objective ideas and and then
you become very angry yeah what angry
people do they they burn and break
things because they're they're dumb and
and dumb people that's how they lash out
it's just it's kind of an inevitable
dominating or two not good combinations
of things to be yeah in an all too
common combination you know I mean there
are some things that's worth getting
angry about but man this is this is not
necessarily just a smart or dumb thing
it's also a virtue versus Vice thing
everyone can have a temper everyone can
get angry the question is do you like
rationally analyze the situation and one
thing I'm really trying to promote here
that we were talking about last night is
the fact that the the battle between
good and evil runs through every man's
heart we can criticize these people for
letting their temp or get the better of
them and doing horrible things but you
gotta ask yourself in my personal life
do I get mad at the people I love for
things that weren't necessarily their
fault uh am I too quick to anger am I
wrathful these are things we've got to
figure out for ourselves if we want to
promote them in society oh for sure yeah
I think so I think the hard truth is
that conservatives believe in emotional
regulation in a way that is not true
everywhere right so if you have this
idea that I need to to be aware of your
feelings and be respectful of them but I
don't have to change everything about
myself to make you happy right that that
has evolved to be a very conservative
way of thinking and I think there is uh
endless pressure uh in different circles
to have
um other people's feelings at the
forethought of everything you do so much
so that you are wired to seek approval
from the group right and yes yeah that's
a huge part of it in this story that we
could like potentially whip a class of
law school students up into a fury over
this this judge who you're completely
right they have never heard of this guy
all they know about him is that he was
appointed by Trump and that was enough
for them to be like well if you're going
I'm going and I'm mad too I'm definitely
I'm mad genuinely I no no I'm very very
mad like just I'm so angry I'm sure the
NPC heads right just being like yes mad
Trump bad mad yeah that's that's very
sad that these are our young legal Minds
right and I'm sure it's not everyone I
don't again I feel bad for all the
Stanford law students who I'm just
throwing under the bus with everyone
else but it is interesting that the idea
that emotions come first and that
compliance the group and emotional
satisfaction through that is right is
the driving force that should be
unnerving to you yeah I mean they're not
doing a good job teaching law students
how to interact with the judge but
continue I was going to say well how
many Stanford law students were whipped
up to this much frenzy that not very far
from their campus are thousands of
homeless people who are defecating on
themselves totally stoned sleeping on
the floor eating garbage being stepped
over by Society have they ever been
whipped into a frenzy about those
policies or and you can make a list of
all of a sudden there are a lot of
things that you could get whipped into a
frenzy about in society there's a lot
that's going wrong in society but yeah
to be whipped into this this judge just
gonna speak this judge I heard of four
minutes ago and and yeah how said I
think the the NPC character nodding is
is is fantastic
absolutely one more point I'll make
about this before we move on to our next
topic just to piggyback off what you
said Hannah Claire about these kids
falling in line that's another huge part
of this it feels good to be part of an
in-group and so if you have spent your
life habituating yourself towards doing
what feels good rather than what makes
sense which is what we're habituated to
do uh and what our educational system is
actually promoting then you're not gonna
think to stand up against the group
you're gonna obey but our next story
here Florida's Matt gates to introduce a
bill to funding Jack Smith investigation
targeting Trump we must act so there's a
bit of a follow-up on a story we told I
believe two days ago where Trump is
insisting that he's going to be arrested
at some point because of this
investigation but representative Matt
Gates announced Tuesday he would be
introducing legislation in the House of
Representatives to defund special
counsel Jack Smith's grand jury
investigation into the January 6th
Capital Riot and efforts to overturn the
2020 presidential election I will be
introducing legislation to defund Jack
Smith's Witch Hunt against President
Trump Gates wrote on Twitter just hours
after former president Donald Trump
confirmed on social media that he had
been notified he was the Target in an
investigation and expected to face an
arrest and indictment they are attacking
our democracy and engaging in election
interference right now the United States
Congress has the capacity to stop this
election interference and we must act
immediately Gates added so how do you
guys feel about this are you happy with
what Gates is doing here do you think
this is the proper strategy to prevent
something like this to occur does he
have any other choice and what do you
think is going to come of the
investigation into Donald Trump we know
they've been desperately trying to nail
him on anything is this what they're
going to finally be able to cook up some
trumped up charges on well Smith's been
trying to get the trial moved
aggressively to December which would put
him right at the heart of the beginning
of the primary season debates
um and people say well okay there's no
statute of limitation on this quote
unquote crime so we don't have to do it
and you know we don't have to do it in
December we could do it in 2026 what's
the rush to have it done now and the
rush clearly is to interfere with the
election so I don't think Congress has
any of their options right the other
options are sadly the riots but I don't
want that to happen right I don't want
to see America devolve into chaos but
there are the mega movement is big and
they're not going to be quiet about it
and so I think it's the first step of
hopefully de-escalating what is
otherwise an abuse of of the doj it's a
clear violation or it's a clear
interference in the election right and
for the Biden Administration to say whoa
hey look this is just the doj acting
autonomously and independently and we
have no common Korean Jean-Pierre is
constantly saying I have you know asked
them about it
um I I think I think if this were
happening in the Congo we would laugh at
it right when this happens in Russia and
Vladimir Putin's opponents all suddenly
disappear right um or get arrested we
laugh at it and so I I applaud them
taking some action legally and they have
the power of the person so this is their
jurisdiction and I think we should see
more of it yeah when I was reading the
story I I guess I hadn't totally put
together that uh Smith is responsible
not just for the January 6th
investigation but he's also the one
leading the probe into the uh classified
document issue that led to the the raid
on Mar-A-Lago you know Trump just pled
last month not guilty to 37 charges
something from the investigation I can't
help but feel like there's some kind of
conflict that this guy who's already
leading an investigation that is going
to trial was like great so now they've
got those charged under we're starting
another one here we go that seems like
complete conflict of interest like why
would we continue to to fund money
towards this person exactly like what
you're saying when it seems like there
is a clear uh timeline issue you have to
question intent when someone who could
bring these try bring these charges
later is like no but we have to do them
now yeah and also now that I have some
Churches on table I want more exactly we
know he's not going to open up a third
they can do this all day long and so
this is from uh gates.house.gov the
power of the purse is not some
intermittent thing that we wield every
fiscal cycle it's something that we have
to wield in day in and day out to
achieve victory for our people and stop
this I'm under No Illusion that the
Democrats will bring such legislation up
in the Senate but the American people
deserve to know where Congress members
stand I I think that's exactly right I
think that's completely fair I think
that something does have to be done
about this and you're right the timing
of this investigation is more than a
little suspicious the idea that well
this is the doj and they just have no
common interest look the Department of
Justice said after Roe was overturned
that they were going to essentially
dishonor what the court wanted they were
going to make sure that these uh
procedures were as protected as they
possibly could be they were also going
to increase their vigilency against
violations of the face act and what that
ended up resulting in was trumped up
charges against the mark Houck the idea
that the left-wing political apparatus
isn't collaborating with itself because
it has so much respect for the idea of
checks and balances within United States
government when these people repeatedly
Say by any means necessary and that
they're interested in the process and
not the results isn't just hopelessly
naive it's actually cynical these people
know what they're doing they know why
they're saying the things that they're
saying and they're exploiting the
American people's good faith I remember
back in 16 when there were all the uh
Trump Clinton things breaking and there
was russiagate right in the pp tape and
all that and you always saw the name you
saw the name Peter stroke and then there
was Hillary Clinton the 33 000 emails
and you saw the name Peter stroke and I
remember thinking does anyone else work
at the doj right like how come this one
yeah and that's what I think of with
Jack Smith now it's like everything is
his case like doesn't the doj have 40
000 people who work there how come this
one guy seems to be getting all the
pictures right now how come he never
goes to his supervisor and can I just
have something else off my plate I'm
really busy these days it's very funny
have the same people get all of these
cases right I'm sure it's just a
coincidence it's just a coincidence that
he's probably not definitely being like
okay but what's the next thing I can
bring against Trump like it how is it
not suspicious to people that the man is
continually investigated by people who
hate him in every investigation up until
this point has shown that he was
innocent that he was not guilty of the
thing that they were alleging and they
just keep launching new investigations
into him and we're supposed to believe
it's not politically motivated it's
insane and I think there are a lot of
cases of this right now where you know
with this case it's the OJ but there are
a lot of attorney generals uh and Trump
has experienced this with Leticia James
in New York who will say we think you
did something wrong give us all your
private information and confidential
data and we'll go through it and then
we'll decide what charges we're bringing
against you just as the founders
intended Justice intended this is this
is the America they promised me right
where you can do so you know under
investigation you are subject to
subpoena you have to comply or else be
brought up on some other kind of charges
unless they decide they like you right
like this is completely about political
favoritism it's not about Justice it's
not about accepting that some people
have different values found a bag of
cocaine at the White House but we don't
know like who cares could be anybody's
yeah
no idea exactly and like it could be any
buddies yeah let's find out who that
makes it scarier it could be anyone at
the White House this bag of coke who's
doing this and shouldn't we be concerned
that the Secret Service who's tasked
with protecting the president can't tell
you where that came yeah some of them
look terrible terrible and instead
they're just like okay well that's over
we don't know it's funny though as that
was coming out I know we're devolving
but I had been in the West Wing a number
of times when I was in the Bush
Administration and and at first they
made it sound like it was in this public
door that everyone walks through and she
kept saying Chris jump here kept saying
it's a highly trafficked area and then
they narrowed it narrowed it and then
when they finally confirmed where it was
you say like you can't I couldn't go
down there right no one can go she meant
drug traffic
so it's so funny and you can narrow the
scope of who has access to that room in
there it's actually a hunter bidenation
that's what the door is hard to say like
the god-shaped hole I have in my heart
shaped hole in the White House no it's
just wildly just hysterical and again I
think that the Biden Administration
should be embarrassed that they're
sacrificing the Secret Service like
you're you're saying as the president
you're not concerned that the people
tasks are protecting you can't figure
out where that came from or else the
obvious you know what I mean it's the
same as the scotus leaker right yeah it
could be don't go after him well okay it
could be anybody but how many people see
the the unredacted draft version of
documents right everyone do you it's
like well we know it so everyone sees
that everyone everyone know what the
Supreme Court is doing so we know it's
this chord now let's get going right so
they make it sound like like why do you
why do you treat us like children just
stop pretending that we're dumb the
American people I know I just called
them dumb perverts when that's sad but
but for the most part of the American
people are not that stupid well they lie
we know that they're lying they know
that we know that they're lying we know
that they know that we know that they
know that they're like
I think that was Soulja netskin yeah oh
yes yes
everyone they continue to I think I
think on some level it's it it almost
comes across as a humiliation rich like
come on this is what you're going with
you don't know who belong to you're not
going to investigate that
um also I mean you just see how
diametrically opposed the situation is
with Trump uh and Joe Biden are those
two situations respectively Trump has
had every single element of his life
turned upside down and had a flashlight
shown on it and we have not found any
illegal accidents so he might be the
least innocent person ever I know and
this is the thing when he first ran I
liked him because of who his enemies
were and he grew on me but I wasn't
gonna say I know that this guy's
innocent I know these investigations are
phony when the Russia gate stuff first
came out and they made these nonsense I
went maybe I have no idea let's see but
then as time went on and I think I just
assumed because he was running for
office that he had legal skeletons in
his closet because that seems to be a
required environment in the United
States But as time went on and they kept
launching these investigations I went oh
my goodness this is amazing squeaky
clean this guy is squeaky clean now with
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden we literally
have whistleblowers at the IRS coming
forward two of them at once to say that
the investigation into Hunter was slow
walked and that every effort was made to
ensure that they weren't going to find
anything and they weren't going to give
them a conviction we had Marjorie Taylor
green yesterday at the house basically
speaking with one of these
whistleblowers
and alleging that Hunter was paying
prostitutes with company money and then
writing it off I mean you actually have
red flags you even have smoking guns
here when you look at what's on the
laptop and there's there's not an
investigation then when there is an
investigation the lightest possible
charges right yeah well I mean we all
knew something was up as soon as they
announced oh actually he's guilty and
here's this deal that we gave him where
no consequences this morning I saw like
more ridiculous pictures surface of him
like it's just it's all desensitized to
it it's complete arrogance on Hunter
Ryan's part first off he knew his dad
has been in public office his entire
life and you're telling me this guy
didn't think to file his taxes like
absolutely not that's complete arrogance
the other thing is with the
Whistleblower yesterday and I just have
to say this and I'll let you go uh my
favorite part was when he was like
talking to Margaret Taylor green he's
like oh yeah yes we do believe at
certain points he was uh he was uh
paying for escorts and listening this
way and you know there's a ten thousand
dollar golf club membership here we
believe that's for a sex club like yes
this guy feels as though no rules apply
to him yeah and that's just insane that
should tell you enough about the Biden
family I think it's impressive that that
you're that you say like you should be
filing his taxes I think he should not
be taking pictures of himself doing blow
with hookers
I've got crackheads
defile taxes it's actually kind of
impressive that he does that at all he's
looking for for write-offs and
workarounds and stuff sounds like a bad
joke how many crackheads file their
attacks
someone else files his taxes for him and
he still couldn't do it meanwhile he's
got an entire laptop full of this
disgusting stuff like I the bar could
not be lower for this person and he
still cannot meet it and we're expected
as the public to accept that he gets a
different type of Justice than everyone
else so someone make fun of Mara Jerry
Taylor green when she was holding up
those photos and they were pretty
graphic and they were like hey hey what
do you think this is
kindergarteners
this is another part of it too so what
routinely happens this is what routinely
happens the Democrats either in the left
either do something disgusting or or
introduce something disgusting into the
discourse and then when we point it out
they go why are you pointing at that
disgusting thing yeah like Marjorie
why'd you show that uh that's the
president of the United States his son
that's what he's doing there's also
evidence of illegal activity here that
should be looked into I think that's a
good reason and I think it's important
to grab people's attention about this
stuff we know that if it was Don Jr we'd
see all of that and far more
um and so again every effort is made to
spare these people every single effort
is is made to ensure there's no
accountability when you have them trying
to put this pornographic content in
schools whoever shows people that
there's this pornographic content is now
the bad guy even when uh we had a guest
on
and Tim brought up some of the
consequences of these horrific trans
surgeries these bodily mutilations the
response from the guest was a response
you get from a lot of left fingers which
is ill why are you talking about this
because you people have created this
you've normalized this it's not the
direction we want our country to go in
and we should speak out against it yeah
it's sickening uh it's sickening but
there are some huh what are you laughing
at just you're gonna interrupt me is
this the rage in this room I feel like
we all drank coffee right before we go
yeah I've been drinking I've been
drinking Coke not doing coke but and if
I was doing it I would take photos and
post them on my laptop and then leave it
somewhere look all decent human beings
who believe there are no consequences to
their actions you know as as bad as the
coke is and the hookers is and all the
bad stuff there is nothing worse than
sleeping with your dying brother's wife
that's pretty bad that is the sign of
the most immoral person you left the
wife your wife and the mother of your
children to hook up with your dying
brother's wife and I say this often and
it's cruel but I do I don't think Beau
uh Biden died of cancer I think he died
of familial shame because that is a
disgusting family yes that is a
disgusting family and I couldn't embrace
my son I love The Prodigal Son but I it
would be hard to embrace your son and
welcome him to the White House knowing
that he is sleeping with your dying Sons
closed captioning not available
[Music]
and to this day a lot of people say
maybe someone else was drunk in that
accident who knows but but the truck
driver from the forensic evidence and at
least when the case was reported was not
the one at fault now accidents happen
and that's tragic but because Joe Biden
is such an a corrupt morally correct to
lie about something like that to become
sympathetic he went from having hairy
legs to a drunk a drunk truck driver
killed my wife and kid yeah because it
makes him sympathetic horrible about
that that happens to lie about this this
was when he was getting he was sworn in
so he has he had three kids with his
first wife his daughter died and then
Beau would Hunter were both hospitalized
and there were images of him being sworn
in for the first time in the hospital
because that's how close this was to
inauguration you mean to tell me you had
the eyes of the Nation on you I'm sure
this story was everywhere and you think
decades later you can just make stuff up
like you have such a low opinion of the
American people it's like making you
know well so many stories he's made of I
don't know if anyone's kept the full
list but arrested going to see uh Nelson
Mandela grew up in the black church
that's my favorite one the Drew up in
the black church and the synagogue and
the cigars you grew up in the black
church and the
Services every weekend he went to
Catholic mess he went to Friday services
Josh what a busy guy uh oh and and back
in the 1950s his father he and his
father saw two gay men kiss and his
father said that's lovely yes that
definitely happened that happened
everywhere he broke good peace deals
with with a gold in my ear when he was a
a law student I was a few broken piece
everything his family was coal miners he
stole that from a very thought about
because of the first presidential one he
ever had because he was like I was first
in my class at law school
no Beau died in Iraq yeah he's told that
to Marines yeah my I lost my son on the
war wait that's not what happened
familial shame I think he was inhaling I
think there was something with the
chemicals
that he was exposed to while deployed
but he came back to the US and then was
an attorney general of Delaware like he
did not die
there's something wrong with the man
there really is something wrong with him
lotion on a strange man's legs but um
yeah man that was that's definitely a
bit of a black bill here we have we have
another story uh here which is I think
uh telling of some of the victory of
Republican strategy and getting the left
to change course on their values which
is also always a fun thing to see them
forced into as Asylum seekers in cities
care tops 54 800. mayor Adam announces
new policy to help Asylum Seekers move
from shelters now this is the way the
media frames this when you are on this
side yeah exactly uh and they want to
protect you if it was a republican doing
this in a red State the story would be
about how he was a horrible man who's
forcing families out onto this streets
New York city mayor Eric Adams today
announced additional policies to help
Asylum seekers in the city's care move
out of shelter and create critically
needed space for arriving families with
children seeking Asylum the city has
made every effort to continue serving
the more than 90 000 Asylum Seekers who
have arrived in New York City since last
spring but with an average of 300 to 500
people still arriving each day and more
than 54 000 migrants still in the city's
Care New York City is that capacity
having responded in the absence of state
or federal action so uh y'all probably
know at this point that another part of
Republican strategy recently which has
actually been very effective is Ben Greg
Abbott busing
migrants up to these blue States and
what the blue states are saying is this
is cruel this is horrible you can't use
people as pawns and we don't have the
resources to sustain them yes I agree
with all of those things let's stop
allowing that to happen at the southern
border as well of course as soon as they
have to see The Economic Consequences
then it becomes a serious issue I love
when they admit that there's just not
room or resources for everyone in the
world who wants to come here this is New
York City this is an incredibly wealthy
part of the country everyone's trying to
leave these are the only people who seem
to want to move to New York right now
and New York is saying no go away we
can't take care of you well if New York
can't afford to take care of these
people what about the impoverished
border towns that are forced to what do
you guys think about this story well
it's a great example of making them live
out their their values and when your
values all are welcome and we will
accept we're a sanctuary City it is just
a matter of of numbers right the the
productive members of society produce
the tax revenue and then the
government's bends it and when that
becomes out of balance and is becoming
out of balance when you look at the
Exodus and I'm like oh yeah you know my
whole family is still in New York City
I'm a proud New Yorker although I Live
Now in a farm and rural Virginia as you
all know and I talk about all the time
but I mean New York City will always be
home and we're 8th generation Seventh
Generation New Yorker but but but the
when you look at the Exodus of people
who are leaving like myself
um it's the it's the The Producers it's
the people and that people are you know
they're trying to blame climate change
but they're going to Florida and Texas
are they actually I saw that climate
climate changes please tell me please
tell me how they're doing it
that was an article today I have to find
it article today about how climate
change is driving a lot of the migration
of of communities but they're all moving
to Arizona Texas and Florida and you're
like well well maybe they want more heat
I guess so it's kind of comical that
that's the accusation they're making but
the value the The Producers not the
sound ironian but the the people who
produce value who produce
Society are the ones leaving and the
people who take as crass as that sounds
migrants who come here with nothing all
they can do for a while is take they
need homes they need shelter they need
food they need health care when that
equation falls out of balance you have
mayor Adams who ran his whole campaign
about how he was a welcoming mayor all
are welcome all are welcome it's a
numbers game
Ayan Rand put it the coldest maybe but
but it is a numbers game and New York is
suffering that numbers game yeah well I
mean this is part of why what you just
explained a moment ago about the fact
that when people first come to the
country generally they are going to be
taking more than they're able to give
this is why we had a system in place why
we do have a system and why we're
supposed to adhere to the system of
sponsor families bringing people in and
then that family can help that person
while they're in the country it's not
all being paid for by taxpayers then
that person actually has an incentive to
get out on their feet because you don't
want to be an adult or a person with a
family living under someone else's roof
not contributing and not being able to
get out of that situation because you
haven't found a job like there's a
structure in place to create the proper
incentives for people who come here to
start producing as soon as possible but
in the United States there are two
fundamental positions when it comes to
Integra immigration there's the position
that we should have laws in the position
that laws are mean and those are
literally the only two positions by the
way within position one that we should
have laws there's a wide variety of
different positions people have on what
those laws should be but the dominant
view is it is mean to enforce those laws
how dare you suggest that they be
respected yeah it comes down to emotions
and rationale yeah for sure fortunately
I think why I have a family friend who's
a Greek descendant and tells the story
about how Greek communities used to send
someone over and they would someone it
started with someone opening a retail
business like it was a grocery store
candy store or something and um
eventually they were able to then bring
over someone else from the small town in
Greece where they were from and
eventually that person was able to move
farther out and start start a store and
there there was a community support
element so much so that she still
attends uh a big family gathering now
they're not all related but it's just
sort of this community event of people
who are descended from literally one
town in Greece that's so cool to me and
I find it interesting that we had
systems that believed in support and
mutual benefit and instead our
immigration policy has gotten so
deranged that we are saying you should
illegal across the border because Eric
Adams will say yes I will help you so
you will elect me and I will look good
but actually when it comes time when
push comes to shove he is now saying uh
so suburbs of New York Orange County you
guys need to house single migrant men in
your hotels and if you don't do so
you're the bad guys how are you not
doing this problem I invited people up
here I don't think I can handle anymore
so now it's your job to start cleaning
up because New York dominates the same
city during that party at someone else's
house and then leaving yeah yes or like
being like yeah I have too many people
coming to visit me so you they all are
gonna stay in your houses around me
because I said so well at least if you
invite me to your house I'm probably
going to bring a bottle of wine yeah you
know but but sometimes our our the folks
that were inviting to this this country
bring nothing right but then or they
want legal substances like fentanyl or
aren't invited
on the list I have a pretty radical and
uh environmental position and I am a no
immigrant position I I am I am not
pro-immigration people say well we need
immigrants they diversity is our
strength I love that and shouldn't be
New York want as many of them like why
why can we not be closed why why do we
need so any immigrants in the people
tell me that they provide this in
tremendous value I see them undercut
wages I see them as a drain on social
systems which I also oppose I am I am a
no immigration I always say if I'm
elected for president there will be no
immigration for like my Administration
yeah the president after me can change
that but we're gonna go four straight
years with no immigration I think an
immigration moratorium is a completely
valid option because we are not just
like struggling with this we are really
in crisis and that is not okay I think
this is I mean I've said it before I
think the open border puts the men and
women and children who are trafficked
across In Harm's Way it hurts the Border
communities it hurts our country overall
I think it hurts people who try to apply
legally to come here because I think
ultimately we do a disservice by
allowing immigration I would be for an
immigration moratorium uh but I can
understand when if you don't really read
about anything and if you're not super
political you're not really into news
and you just hear sob story after sob
story about how actually the people who
say this stuff are racist and actually
they they are harmful to everyone you
know I could understand where you would
be misled and probably from a very sweet
nice place of compassion it's just not
accurate I'm also married to an
immigrant I have to make that clear
well I I want to mention Australian if
that counts but I mean they're kind of
American as far as a moratorium goes I I
just like it's not one of those things
where I go oh that's bad that's racist I
just haven't seen the numbers to know
whether that's necessary no I think I
think if we I think if a moratorium
becomes necessary absolutely I don't
know the stats I do know that we have
had an unprecedented and unsustainable
number of people pouring across the
border I think in an ideal situation a
country should be able to welcome
immigrants who are coming to try to make
a better life for themselves right but
it's important for political leaders to
do the hard work of maintaining the
standard of living for the citizens who
were born there and who live there and
not just allow anyone into the country
when that is going to come at a
tremendous burden for the population of
that country there's a hospital near
Dulles Airport Port called I think it's
Stone Springs that friends of mine who
live in that area used to tell me they
have a sign outside for the ER five
minute wait four minute wait
um but now we we we train or we fly uh
multiple flights per day of illegals and
we drop them off and the first thing
they do is they go to the airport and
now the local community says the ER or
the local hospital excuse me thank you
and now the local community says well
now the ER has a 15 18 20 25 and they're
like what what's going on what well
that's the result of unchecked
immigration well exactly you don't have
diverticulitis or a heart attack because
your services are now severely
encumbered well it's a reality that's
not bad or good it's well it's bad but
it's reality well okay and so it's this
there was one time I think where you
could have the left if they were
remotely consistent or cared about the
things they claim to care about you
could even have the left making an
argument for a moratorium and that was
during coven people weren't allowed to
go to work people weren't able to visit
their loved ones in the hospital they
were dying people funerals of loved ones
because this disease was just too
dangerous and everyone was going to die
if it was allowed to spread but we were
just letting people into the country
it's like that's absolutely insane
people don't have the freedom to go from
their house to their job and you're
saying people have the freedom to go
come from anywhere in the world into our
country when this is the time of a
pandemic I mean I'm not asking for a
moratorium I'm just asking for or laws
to be followed this is crazy that we're
even having this debate what the
discussion should be about is what are
the immigration laws instead our
discussion is should we follow them
should we enforce the immigration laws
we have that's totally insane we didn't
even Force vaccines on the illegals we
didn't if you migrated legally you had
to do the code vaccine but if you cross
the border illegally you did not have to
this is craziness and again it only
punishes people who try to operate in a
respectful way to our laws which I find
to be abhorrent like why are we allowing
this and I I just think you know the the
fact is you can't have a logical
conversation about immigration because
people feel uncomfortable talking about
implications of race or diversity or
whatever else and that's fine you try to
do it in a respectful way but if you
bear out the numbers like one of the
examples I was reading recently is that
uh Tech job uh salaries have been
stagnant for a long time and part of
that is because we actually have an
oversupply of workers because of H-1B
visas uh if we didn't have that we would
have an industry that becomes
competitive again I find it interesting
that people can't bear out that like
immigration has consequences for the
population and sometimes we have to say
no and it's not out of hatred it's just
out of protection for Son of love
you immediately like the basic human
goodness and decency wants to be able to
say like what Sheamus was saying like
yes we would like people to be able to
come to this country like everyone did
originally and if you don't do it the
right way though we can't possibly be
able to say okay well how do we make
that work because we don't have like the
numbers in the balance sheet to make
everything make sense and if we have
like you know it just we have to have
numbers and stuff on that and no one
knows those numbers right they're all
made up so this is this is this is a a
point that I made years ago I remember I
was out to dinner with a group of
friends probably about eight years ago
now and this was when a shooting had
happened in Paris there was a radical
Theocratic Islamic extremist is that the
Charlie hebdo it may have been I think
it may have been I I can't remember the
particulars of the situation but I
remember we were out to dinner I got the
news notification you know I looked at
the article and went oh my goodness this
is horrible and a girl that I was out to
dinner with with my friends uh who I
hadn't met before she said you're only
upset about it because it's happening in
the first world and I said
horrible things like this happen in the
third world all the time and when they
start happening in the first world which
is anomalous in the sense that it is the
first time in history we have had this
much wealth this much peace this much uh
strength in terms of Law and Order at
least in certain countries we did uh and
when we chip away at that it doesn't
make the third world better it just
means there are now fewer places in the
world where people aren't being killed
by these Rogue theocrats and so what
what leftists will do is they'll say
okay well you know your country is very
wealthy and you're upset about these bad
things happening in your country but
you're not concerned about what's
happening in the migrants country or why
they need to come here okay but here's
the point if the way of life that we
have here is eliminated it's not going
to come back it's it's very like that it
won't come back for a very very long
time and it's not going to make life
better for the people in these countries
that they're trying to escape there's
just going to be nowhere left to run to
you brought up a great point and I agree
with everything you say I'm just I'm
impressed at your kindness because my
answer to that is yes yeah like I am
concerned it's happening yeah absolutely
because no that's what I said
yeah
concerned about my country right if you
say to be concerned about what's
happening in Rwanda okay well rwandans
are worried about that and now we're
worried about that who's responsible for
worrying about what happens in America
yep right nobody if someone has I love
how leftists can make accusations like
that you're only concerned because it's
happening in your country damn straight
yeah I was like yes
cancer because she's your mom yes
exactly exactly but this girl thing or
dinner with I bet she said that no hold
on it was a group of us I was not like
on a date with this girl okay I just
want to be clear Davis has never been on
a date not once not a single time I want
you all to know not with that kind of
woman uh oh okay no girls who would date
you very gladly no I was I'm honestly
again not liberal but here's the thing
if they're liberal women I love this no
no stop talking I'm done with it this is
this is uh no this is love doctor with
James but what I'm gonna say is this
girl who you were at dinner in a group
with turned to you and said this because
she feels as though she has to knock you
out of head do you think this girl
thinks about the third roll ever when it
comes to you no except
one Outlet in the third world in a third
world country ask her to name one new
surf one journalist one political leader
she could not do it she only said it to
make you feel bad yeah which is
disgusting well fortunately it didn't
work no it didn't work and I don't think
she was expecting it wasn't a second
time I mean there wasn't a second we
were literally out for a friend's
birthday and it was one of her it was it
was one of her friends it was an
interesting conversation anyway so the
left
problem and
when it comes to people entering the
country illegally when it comes to
people committing violent crime when it
comes to groups that they consider to be
marginalized or oppressed but then they
become proponents of ruling with an iron
fist whenever it comes time to prosecute
somebody on the right or who has done
something that the left diffuses a
threat to their power so a judge has
denied a bid by Q Shaman to toss out his
January 6th conviction a federal judge
Thursday denied a bid by January 6th
rioter Jacob chansley better known as
the Q Shaman they're calling him Q Anon
Shaman it's Q Shaman okay to vacate why
would you know that though
to vacate his conviction in light of
footage not incoming investigation you
know this is I'm done for now HC sorry
um to vacate his conviction in light of
footage from the capitol that day aired
by X Fox News host Tucker Carlson
chansley who stood out from the January
6th crowd for wearing face paint and a
horned headdress I actually thought he
fit in pretty well I don't know if he
stood up tearing the riot pleaded guilty
to obstruction and was sentenced uh in
November 2021 to 41 months now this is
something I want to mention I was
obviously being a little tongue-in-cheek
there what happened on j6 was on one
side of the building
you did have people who broke through
the window and broke in on the other
side of the building the police
literally opened the doors and let
people in so you had just a lot of
regular people who were there as
protesters who are walking through and
uh were catching charges because of it
it's crazy there was actually a judge
who had to let somebody off because the
footage that they had of the event
proved that he basically went and told
to spoke to a police officer and he he
wasn't told that he couldn't leave in
order to charge someone with trespassing
they can't think that they're allowed to
be there but of course we know that uh
the left they don't care about law order
at all and that goes in two directions
that goes a in the direction of not
Prosecuting people who are breaking the
law and of course Prosecuting people who
didn't break the law and refusing to
exonerate someone even when footage
comes out showing that they were not
guilty of the crime of which they were
accused now that said in this particular
story
I can't give you all the intricacies and
details it's possible that they still
had something on him but overall with
the pattern that I've seen with these
hearings they're all too willing to be
as harsh as possible on people who
really either have a very good excuse or
actually didn't break the law at all uh
and there are some people who were
genuinely violent who should be locked
up there's no question about that but
again we don't see any of the people who
broke down the barricades at the White
House being arrested there was not an
investigation into the 2020 riots
despite a majority of the American
population wanting investigations
according to polling data far more
people than wanted investigations into
January 6 because the j6 you know
investigations were not about protecting
the American people or our democracy
they're about protecting people in power
and having you ignore the fact that
cities were literally set on fire and
allowed to burn for several months at a
time well it is a crime to withhold
exculpatory evidence and that's what the
36 committee yeah it's true did and and
if if that had been extended to other
famous cases you think of uh hands up
don't shoot you think of of of Kyle
Rittenhouse right when evidence comes
out different angles different cameras
different footage and you get to paint
the whole picture it somehow changes the
verdict a little bit because the jury
sees everything there was no jury
obviously in the j6 uh trial but the
fact that they withheld all of this and
obviously this footage wasn't brought
into Jacob chanslee's uh it's a shameful
for the judge right and it's shameful
for Benny Thomas and the entire j6
committee and all the people who partook
of it that's why the Republicans turned
so much on on on
um Liz Cheney why they turn so much on
Alan kinziger not because they were part
of j6 but because they they knew that
they were withholding evidence like this
they knew that they were withholding in
crucial pieces of data to tell the full
story
um and wanted to for you know to at
Trump and that's that's an unforgivable
crime yeah I I mean I think you're right
this is a a complete perversion of of
Justice I I do remember reading that
story now that you might mention it that
evidence was actually withheld I mean
again these people care nothing for rule
of law they don't care about the process
they care about the outcome yeah the
evidence that Tucker showed of the
Capitol Police walking Jake I saw that
yeah walking him up the stairs and the
door was locked they found another door
they opened up the door they walked them
to the floor of the captain gave him a
back rub brought him his Coco he gave
his prayer thank you Lord God Almighty
for the United States Senate thank you
for the Capitol Police for keeping us
safe and then they walked him out and he
went home yep uh so again people could
say well he still broke the law by being
there but that really changes things a
little bit from The Narrative that they
showed at j6 well yeah I mean it's hard
to say that somebody is a trespasser
when police officers literally walk them
through the building and tell them that
they can be there I mean I mean you
would have thought if he was doing
something illegal they would have
perhaps been the one to notice it yeah
yeah it's kind of crazy I know that's a
crazy expect the police were in on the
Insurrection yeah but why aren't they
getting brought up on trucks
had ever showed who were those cops
those cops now have to test if I why did
you walk Jacob chansley and you get an
order did you how did you think and we
already made the Capitol Police the
heroes of this story yeah I mean so
unraveled I was um I got the chance to
sit in on opening uh on when we did
opening statements for the proud voice
trial this this group of guys that were
uh selected by the U.S government to
represent the masterminds of the
conspiracy right because there were a
couple people who they like swapped in
and out at the last minute it was it was
crazy uh but one of the things that I
remember the most and I wrote about it
for Tim cast news if you want to find
that article uh is uh thanks thanks uh
was that the US government first and it
was like here is a clip of text messages
they're having or here is a video or
here is a voice moment and then all you
know each each man was represented by
their own attorney so there were a lot
of attorneys they had a lot of lots to
say but most of the time they just
expanded it instead of taking one tiny
clip like the US government they were
like here is the context of what they're
saying and it was very difficult to
believe one of the attorneys there said
it best these men couldn't organize
ordering as a group from McDonald's do
you think they organized a conspiracy
but the fact of the matter is you know
the U.S government the in really the
American Media needs someone to take the
fall they need to have whipped the
people into a frenzy and they cannot say
that there was no one at fault here yeah
and that to me is disturbing right
because we are not uh carrying out
Justice for the people we are carrying
out Justice for these corporations and
the administrative bloat that says we
did the right thing and we will prove it
to you with our own tools well even the
whole narrative surrounding January 6th
and the idea that it's an Insurrection
is so unbelievably ridiculous these
people were grasping at any straw they
can possibly grab out to try to indict
and criminalize uh Donald Trump or
prosecute Donald Trump make him out to
see him as if he was trying to subvert a
democratic process when in reality they
were doing that with this fraudulent
nonsensical investigation into Russian
interference in the 2016 election and
his collaboration with them when you
actually looked narrative what they're
effectively saying is that Donald Trump
the commander-in-chief
the president of the United States the
most powerful person on the planet with
all of the resources available to the
executive branch and his fingertips
wanted to overturn a fair and free
election and his genius plan to do so
was by dog whistling to a bunch of
Boomers to go inside of the capital and
not do anything violent yeah what was it
great he literally an incredible plan he
literally said go have your voices heard
he didn't tell them to be violent he
told me non-violent he told him to go
protest yeah not not break in but even
so even so if he had some kind of secret
dog whistle that only the other
conservatives could hear and that's why
they went in there it seems like a
pretty lame thing to dog whistle when
you're trying to overthrow the United
States government to get it to get a
group of people I mean it's the most
really was a mostly peaceful
Insurrection it was the only person who
was harmed the only person who was
harmed was one of the protesters poor
Ashley about it that woman was that
woman was killed that woman was killed
if someone was killed at a BLM protest
they would be a martyr for the country
I'm not kidding we would have statues of
them we would have statues of them the
police officer who shot them would be
locked up we would melt the key down and
then pour the metals it was made of down
the drain
yeah I mean I think you're right so I'm
desperately digging in my backpack
because I have a relevant note looking
for a point to make well I
someone told me that there was another
protester at January 6 who um had a
heart attack and then later died but we
don't hear his name so I'm just trying
to see if I can pull my notes on this
well but um well I mean I'll give you a
second to find those but this is
something
journalists listen I think that person
was still on the mall actually yeah my
facts are right I think that person
would didn't even make it to the Capitol
and I think they were older I think they
were have Kevin Greeley has a name
nobody quote me on this media I'm just
looking back at my notes the media but
it is interesting because people did
suffer because of these rights and the
representation is that they were all
armed and dangerous and crazy and Donald
Trump sent them there and meanwhile uh
the video showed these supposed leaders
saying no one go in don't go in there
like this is the worst Insurrection ever
if the leaders who comp who apparently
conspired to do this are telling you not
to go in there yeah it's a really bad
idea I just don't understand and and
especially because we did not see the
same kind of vicious pursuit of people
who really did burn businesses in the
summer of 2020 how can you say that this
is worth spending I'm gonna go back to
our first story uh millions of dollars
investigating right yeah become we don't
have a system of justice that represents
people outside of Washington if you are
an American voter and you had a business
that burned in in Minneapolis or in any
major city and you know that they just
said well we're gonna let them go they
didn't feel heard and it's okay but
because it happened to us the federal
government we are going to use the full
weight of our purse strength to go after
these things so that's exactly right
fast it shifted Focus from like
everything else they were going after
Trump four and then all of a sudden like
I was watching it live and I'm like okay
so now this has happened everything else
was forgotten about essentially yeah and
the main focus and the show trial on
this for the next however many years
yeah and all for what like it's crazy
absolutely one thing uh all HC over
there mentioned that I want to touch on
was that there were there were people
who who passed there and what ended up
happening is there were people
who didn't die at January 6th but died
later yeah and then it was like covid-19
where we just said they died with
January 6th and it was like because of
January 6 that they died even though
they died a significant amount of time
later I mean what what a ridiculous way
of measuring the mortality of an event
did we do that for the BLM rights by the
way did we did we consider any of the
people who committed suicide or died
because their business was burnt down
did we keep track of whether that
happened to add to that uh death count
no of course not because they were again
they were grasping at straws to make it
into something that it wasn't Kevin
greeson is the name was looking for okay
no I just I think that you're totally
right thank you I think it was and I
remember this feeling so so the night of
all of this I was actually
um working on like an old house that I
was flipping and I remember I have such
a vivid memory of listening to this on
my phone and like throughout that day
because I was um I was new to hanging
drywall and I was doing the thing where
you like put up the joint compound on
the tape and you have to scrape it off
and I'm not great at it but I remember
listening to us and just thinking like
the hysterics that went on in Congress
afterwards thinking like you guys didn't
care when this happened to your
constituents you did not care when this
happened until it was North it's not
that you know any Riot is necessarily
okay it's just there's no equity in the
Justice here there's no there's no
belief that because it happened
somewhere else it's just as valuable as
when it happens in DC the the hysterics
have to have a consequence because if
you're a member of Congress and your
currency is politics then words have to
have a objective value and truth and so
when you have people like congresswoman
Ocasio or Cortez who I know is an easy
punching bag
um and I hate to pile on but when she
says to Ted Cruz like you almost had me
killed on January 6th then you find out
wait you did like a cop showed up to
your office and said hey are you okay
your office is four and if anyone's been
to the capital grounds and I used to
work on Capitol Hill your office is
nowhere near the cabinet it's the
capital complex but it's it's far you
can't even hear the the January 6 riots
from her office and you say well there's
a value that there's there has to be a
consequence I don't know if it's censure
I don't know if it's what but when you
when you foment hysteria and you pile on
and you say I was almost killed on
January 6th and you say well you're only
doing that to throw fuel to the fire and
that's dangerous but our politicians do
this all the time well again when Trump
and his family when the literal
president of the United States and his
family were forced into the presidential
bunker that was hilarious everyone was
joking about that who cared it was
actually really the only combination
condemnation we got was uh the
condemnation of trump for actually
clearing the protesters away and then
going to uh the historic St John's
Church and having pictures taken
everyone freaked out about that how
could he do that
he's holding the Bible Bible he's
holding the Bible as if rule of law is
compatible with Christianity
you need to stop derailing right now
let's get a really good segue quiet the
speed next story today
um speaking of Segways here's my next
segue and my next question
they'll love this segments are you
kidding me someone needs to make a super
cut of my Segways they're all really
good asking for attention on the
internet don't tell the girls about that
either listen I don't have to ask for it
I get it uh Louisiana lawmakers
overturned Governor's veto on gender
affirming care ban for transgender
miners Now ladies and gentlemen you all
know how I feel about this exact kind of
framing gender affirming care ban
firstly it's child mutilation okay it's
also ABC News it's ABC News no I I don't
expect anything better but sometimes
it's fun to read these articles so that
we can not only give people the truth
but show them how the media lies an
exercise of sorting through the nonsense
right and no one can claimed that we
only use one side because that's right
this is your bizarre that's right put
that my dating profile Anna Claire Baton
Rouge Louisiana's republican-dominated
legislature overturned democratic
government John Bel Edwards recent veto
a ban on gender affirming care for
transgender minors on Tuesday Louisiana
where the ban is scheduled to go into
effect on January 1st 2024 will join 20
other states that have enacted laws
restricting or Banning General affirming
care which includes puberty blockers
hormone treatment and gender
reassignment surgery so hold on a second
hold on a second includes gender resign
research I thought that never happens to
minors ever it's not crazy most of those
States face now lawsuits and that's just
not good writing I would write now face
lawsuits but am I wrong here we've got
States face now lost yeah that's just
ABC you should be ashamed I mean like
and in some places you shouldn't the
bands have been temporarily blocked by
federal judges how do you guys feel
about this huh this overturning of this
legislation I mean it's sick the media
comes to their defense they call it Care
One article I I saw about this and I see
this periodically whenever Republicans
do literally the only same thing you
possibly can do and say don't mutilate
children is Republicans are trying to
restrict transgender youth from
receiving Health Care as if the
Republicans are going
you want your kidney removed and
replaced but your transgender like no
they're saying you can't mutilate a kid
because that's not actually Healthcare
yeah I I would love to ask John Bell
Edwards the governor who tried to
overturn this who drovedo this law and
I'm glad he was overturned I just have a
quick question since you are uh not up
for re-election actually the
gubernatorial races is is happening
already in in Louisiana he's served as
two terms
um John Bel Edwards has been fairly
conservative Democrat
um but now is he auditioning for a role
hoping that Biden wins reelection does
he want to be a cabinet secretary is he
auditioning for uh ambassadorship
somewhere I mean he's clearly looking
for his next gig and he says well heck
I'm a Democrat I have to start doing
Democrat things because if you ask the
people of Louisiana I think their
legislators represent them Louisiana is
a fairly conservative State very red
State America is a fairly concerned
conservative country that's right and no
one supports this and so I just curious
that John Bel Edwards would veto this I
just wonder what he hopes what is it
what role is he auditioning for
um probably Secretary of Energy you know
I mean he's from Big Oil and Gas State I
assume Jennifer granholm one of the the
dumbest members of the cabinet and
that's a really low bar have you met
Pete butterjudge
um so I assume he's trying to audition
for a cabinet role and he was like maybe
if I support the trans agenda Biden will
give me give me a job so um shame on
John Bell Edwards but unsurprising at
the end of the day a democrat's gun a
Democrat yeah I mean especially
important to point out that he is out of
time in the in his state government like
he's already been the governor unless
he's going to try and run for Senate
which I don't think he could get elected
from from Louisiana uh there's no room
to go except to join the Biden
Administration if there is a second term
of the Bible Administration uh you know
I love these stories because I like to
see our laws at work right like it is
interesting that Louisiana's lawmakers
said no we don't want this and he was
like I'm gonna do it anyways and you're
like no you're not and I think that that
must be a real a real victory for the
residents of Louisiana who voted for
their their Congress their uh state
state leaders to come up and be brave
because it is not an issue even in red
states that people uh typically want to
talk about that feel comfortable uh
rejecting because again the language
around it is so much like you are you
are voting against giving trans children
uh orthodontia or until you read the
second paragraph and it's like oh my God
yeah exactly what is this exactly and I
think that's like the strangest thing
which if I were to say to you
conservatives voted to protect uh
at-risk skews from undergoing
unnecessary medical procedures you'd be
like oh wow cool that seems like it
could be good mentally unstable youth
yeah permanently scarring yeah right
vulnerable populations would you tell us
over and over and over again are subject
to all kinds of mental health risks that
you know other people are not should not
be experimented on if I told you that
you would agree with me but if I soon as
I tell you I'm a conservative I'm
against letting minors undergo hormone
and and surgery
then you're against it that's bizarre
that's bizarre I have a question I got a
question for you remember how you just
said
um you died with covid you died of coven
and they assumed everyone with covid and
you died with January 6 and died of
January 6. since all the data shows that
that miners who have this this
mutilation done to themselves their
suicide rate goes up yep should they be
considered died of trans surgery or died
with trans yeah so so I've looked there
there's a bunch of different ooh type
four man there's a bunch of different
well they weren't studies that I've seen
uh on this and some of them will claim
that oh when you do these interventions
you actually see a decrease in suicide
right I've looked into those studies the
ones that I've seen are pretty
nonsensical
um there's a study that I won't even get
into pulling well maybe I will so there
was there was a a survey done in 2015 of
like 27 000 transgender people but the
way it was done was by reaching out to
advocacy groups and then having those
groups find people people to answer
these questions so Rachel Levine was was
interviewed okay yeah so so basically
what ended up happening was this data
was parsed through by Jack turban of
Stanford University and they released
this statement about they released this
study based on this data just I think a
year or two ago and they said look this
study proves that Health outcomes and
life outcomes uh get better for people
because what we actually were able to do
with this study was measure trans youth
who who got health care and I hate that
term
transgender transgender identifying yeah
um and we saw the ones who could get who
could get the hormones and and
um then puberty blockers and those who
couldn't well and we found the life
outcomes were better for the people who
were able to get these puberty blockers
well there's several issues with that
which is firstly one of the reasons a
person won't qualify for these
treatments is because they have
significant mental health issues to the
point where that doctor doesn't feel
comfortable giving it to them so in the
group of people who weren't able to
receive the treatment you would already
expect for there to be worse mental
health outcomes and none of that was
normed for and also what the study did
is they took men taking estrogen and
women taking testosterone and lumped
their results together is if that's the
same kind of treatment so what they did
end up finding was that one of those
groups had their suicide rate go up
after they started taking hormones and
the other didn't but then they just
squished it all together to hide that
and make it seem like taking those
hormones is better for you there's also
a bunch of other issues with that survey
there's a bunch of other issues with the
other studies they claim there have been
I think the most credible and reliable
studies that have come out about this
not and again I'm not basing this on
liking the results but I'm talking about
studies that have like looked through
actual medical data in Nordic Europe
have found that there's actually an
increased suicide rate once you get far
enough out from the surgery about 10
years you see a massive Spike this stuff
isn't good for people even the studies
that that purport to show that suicide
rate or or life goes down or life
outcomes increase increase will show it
occurring to like a very marginal degree
that doesn't even put that person in
line with the rest of the population so
you end up engaging in this this
mutilation for a very slight even
negligible benefit but again that's a
slight or negligible benefit within like
a year or two often based on small
sample sizes and poorly collected data
that doesn't go all the way out to that
10-year Mark where more credible Studies
have shown the suicide rate really
increases it's very hard also to survey
people who committed suicide yeah yeah
there's notoriously and that's why so
there was uh there was a study out of
exactly there was a study out of Sweden
that went over hundreds and hundreds of
different people's medical histories uh
and and they compared people who had
been diagnosed with dysphoria who
received treatment for you know
dysphoria or in other words I shouldn't
say treatment for dysphoria who had
these mutilating interventions those who
didn't and then the general population
and what they found out just by looking
at those those medical records was that
hospitalizations for suicide doubled
among the people who who had received
the intervention so we're going to go to
super chats now so I want you all to
smash that like button and share this
video If you enjoyed it join us at
timcast.com join as a member to watch
the live show where viewers will be
calling in and speaking to us live it's
also uncensored so we get to say all the
things that we want to say here but
don't get to because of YouTube I'm not
your buddy I've been holding in words
all day and I can't wait to just let
them all out let them all out you have
to come to the episode card is going to
get wild I'm gonna get wild I'm not your
buddy guy he says now more than ever we
need to lock Shields with Trump we
cannot allow corrupt evil deceptive
traitors dictate who can or cannot be
elected also yes there are many traders
who are aiding in the West's controlled
demolition ooh spicy agreed how do you
guys feel about that
uh yeah I agree yeah I agree okay I
agree
um Raymond g Stanley Jr says Sheamus did
you see Mary's interview with Knowles
how dare she I did and that was I didn't
see the whole thing why would I watch
all of that but I saw a clip of it I saw
the moment where she smeared me and it
was unbelievable
um I gotta see that you really don't you
really don't I would advise you will not
watch it uh it was it was it was behind
the paywall that they have you want to
see you want to see the Tim cast
conversation behind the paywall okay
yeah
um I think his audience was disappointed
that she was there instead of me and may
I say open Ian's that is how she opened
and then they they lobbed some uh
completely unfounded accusations of me
you watched the whole thing no no no no
I I just I I well how could I said
through that people sent me clips they
said look at these horrible smears
um and may I say Ian's transition of my
SC to ask about pardoning everyone was
masterful the vague didn't let down with
the answer
wonderful Ian had some fun transitions
my favorite was he was talking I can't
even remember now yeah how do you feel
about colonizing Mars
[Laughter]
just roll with it yeah you have a big
did a great job I I thought it was a
great interview with him yeah uh satosha
catergator oh boy she said finally I
have a chance to tune in to timcast this
week while I made a public apology to
Sheamus for accusing him of stealing
spoons Michael Knowles convinced me this
morning that Sheamus is at least
stealing something yeah apparently a lot
of free rent out of your head
that's a good one thank you unbelievable
all these criticisms all these attacks
I'm sick of it I'm exhausted yes that's
an even evil villain energy right now I
wish you could see it he's like they're
making me struggle with their
accusations I wouldn't do that I
wouldn't do this I wouldn't you guys
know me I wouldn't I wouldn't take I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do something
like this I wouldn't take Tim spoons
it's I wouldn't you know me I wouldn't
do that I haven't seen any spoons around
here though
yeah and then where then then where
would I put them if I took them oh my
gosh are you the leak Carter because I
will freak out I have two forks in my
studio oh so you're not weighing into
this debate at all other things to say
there are no spoons in our office well
I'm kind of insinuating that maybe he
took them but I don't have any proof
okay
I wouldn't do that one evil Chef said I
would like to take a Libertarian stance
in today's culture drop the drinking age
to 18. you should be young dumb and
learn your lessons raise the voting age
to 38 you should you shouldn't control
lives until you learn slash survive 18.
look I I'm certainly not opposed to
raising the voting age uh I also this is
an interesting thing people will talk
about the fact that
in Europe the drinking age is is much
lower I think in a functional country
you can and do have a lower drinking age
you're an adult 18 you should be able to
drink however we don't raise virtuous
adults who can handle anything let alone
their liquor today so I kind of
understand why it's at 21. well and I
think our 18 year old uh limit is weird
like a lot of the four countries have a
graduated system so you could drink beer
when you're younger right like parents
you can drink at home things like that
and I think that encourages a culture
that has alcohol be a part of it and you
learn to drink in a calm way you learn
to drink you know at meals socially uh
you know there was I always referenced
this but there were a there was a group
of University presidents who led by the
University of the president of Dartmouth
University I believe who said we want to
uh lower the drinking age to 18 because
we want people to not come to college
campuses and start binge drinking that's
a good point right I showed up to
college and I was already a pro really
yeah why did you get kosher home or you
just had a lot well I just drank a lot
in high school yeah same same in from
and but I mean and responsibly also but
right from an Irish Catholic Family in
New York City we drank you know parents
are so mad right now I I you know I
would be in favor of no drinking age
whatsoever but if we're going to talk
about changing uh ages everything has to
be consistent so I would raise the
voting age to 21 because I do not feel
like you should be able to vote which is
the most uh uh uh full expression of
participation in a republic about people
who uh cannot partake in that Republic
so when you have 18 year olds telling 21
21 year olds you can't have a beer but
you have 18 year olds sending them to
war right I have a problem with that so
if I am old enough to vote I'm old
enough to do everything in that in that
functional Republican if I'm not able to
do some of it then I can't vote in it
right interesting see I disagree I think
that there's there's good reason to say
like all right you're an adult but you
still can't vote just because
historically
you couldn't vote till you were 21 but
people were basically on their own
providing for themselves from the time
they were 16. so you had a couple years
under your belt of like learning about
what the world was before you were able
to you know you you paid rent before or
built a house
did you just not all me did you just
hashtag not all did you point out yes of
course I'm speaking in general
do you want me to highlight every
individual case of every single person
who's ever voted so that I can parse
through and people were on their own
yeah I think that's General too although
so you were expected to be able to
provide for yourself by that point so so
this I think what you're talking about
is responsibility you know yeah so we
don't raise people to be responsible
search coming in to break up this fight
well I was going to say with Hannah
Claire's points some um different uh
I'm losing the word right now culture
yeah like some um like men will live
with their families until they get
married right right like until they're
like 30 something yeah Italians yeah
yeah and Mom still does my laundry and
and absolutely Mamma Mia yeah yeah I
just I want to quickly finish my point
though I was gonna say that I think the
responsibility is is hugely important I
think that's what everyone's talking
about here where if you boil it down
you're talking about responsibility to
say like oh well yeah alcohol does this
to me and I can restrain myself from
drinking too much of it and that doesn't
happen I went to high school in
Singapore and that drinking age is 18
there and you know I like at some point
when you when when all the seniors in
high school are turning 18 you know
you're able to drink and you're still
going to school you're still expecting
people to control yourself and handle
yourself yes like you said when you came
to school in Texas right yeah yeah yeah
people people you know binge drink like
crazy and it's wild to see that when I
show up in college and I was like wow
these people are like just unhinged it's
just wild the culture here but anyways
yeah search is it just me or is there no
right way to pronounce this next thing I
don't uh uh it's not like inappropriate
or anything
I mean Lego myth again yeah I think
that's what we're going with that's good
Biden claiming to grow up in a black
church
[Laughter]
I shouldn't laugh I shouldn't laugh
because you know what he said he said
not a joke not a joke but as if also
yeah Biden claiming to grow up in a
black church is like the real life
version of Steve Martin's character
recounting his life in the movie The
Jerk when he said I was a small black
child he's a classical dishonest lawyer
from an era when you could be when you
couldn't be fact-checked yeah here's the
thing man now that elon's in charge he
can be fact checked because even in the
technological era they weren't they
weren't doing it to him they weren't
fact checking old sleepy Joe but he has
so many different identities
I'm not I'm not one to diagnose from
afar with anything other than dementia
but I gotta say getting like changes of
BPD over here with this guy he feels
like he's just a different person in
every room of course I'm being facetious
here we know that this is not a medical
condition this is just being a
politician these people will adopt
whatever identity helps them in any
given instance he just happens to be
like particularly good at it yeah he is
he'll become a different guy but it was
easier career out of it right it was
easier to do that in 1970 when there
wasn't an internet but now there is and
he still does it he's Walter Mitty
Jewish Community I grew up with the
Puerto Rican Community name a community
he's grown up in it it's just all of the
communities he was like there was like a
big Venn diagram of communities and he
was like just in that dot right in the
middle you didn't know Scranton was the
most diverse in all of America in 1950.
that's true you know most people think
it was all white coal miners but
actually it was not it was the most
diverse microcosm of all America in 1940
what are the different churches he said
he was in he's been in the uh definitely
Puerto Rican Community black church
Jewish synagogue he went to daily uh he
went to mass every Sunday
um he's very busy I'm sure when he was
in India he told them I I grew up in
going as seeking his temples and no joke
yeah because I grew up in the grew up in
the Indian church not a joke
uh all right so we have
cashby saying it is heartening to see
strong Americans making a difference Bud
Light sound of Freedom try that in a
small town let's keep pushing that
freedom economy yeah businesses that are
you know I'm reading a guest Super Chat
this is their hard-earned money you just
have to businesses that are hiring given
our AI powered applicant tracking system
a look
I emoji
res Genie yeah I was just gonna say also
your friend who you went out to support
in Nebraska I feel like that's a good
sign too right it is all sorts of cool
things happening in American culture we
shouldn't be too cynical about them we
also should not take them for granted
right
Trevor good job buddy so proud of that
kid and he just like damned you on
Twitter
um yeah DM me on Twitter and said could
you help us out with this and and I
would do it again I mean there's this is
happening and and I'm sure I will put
anyone on the spot but I'm sure other
people in these situations would you
know my school board I I know people do
this I know people involved in the trend
stuff in the school level and they say
my school board's pushing this can you
help us with our school board vote can
you help us with that and they show up
because this is what we do so I love it
that's awesome Sheamus's lesson no no
just no sorry some super chats they're
just these these Rascals in chat he's
accusing you of something absolutely not
no they know it's good for him X Y and Z
said medically assisted self-harm that
is a great way of putting it it's a
great way
yeah Mash we'll start calling it Mash
medically assisted self-harm oh that's
awesome yeah that's a good acronym thank
you Canada yeah I've got kind of a brain
frag was that TMI X Y and Z I give it up
to you don't let Sheamus steal your
thunder it's okay well he didn't say
that he I was the one who came over the
acronym for I was the one who noticed
what the first letter of every word was
okay that takes something of a genius
right yeah they capitalize it but okay
Serge is really moderating tonight yeah
yeah I'm not sure what to make of this
uh I I think I could maybe work most of
that into an article there is an
obligation with language to like when
when we're writing to like not give in
to the left bias right the gender
affirming care but also not lean so far
verbose that you're also just leaning
into a different Echo chamber
um so it's definitely an interesting
suggestion I tend to say and it's really
awkward uh medical inter or medical
gender related intervention services or
something like that and the thing is if
it makes these types of Articles very
difficult it doesn't feel like my best
writing because it's the most awkward
phrasing of all time yeah but I don't
know it's mind-blowing yeah but
philosophy of language we were talking
about this before the show started
that's why the left dominates the
language conversation Wittgenstein would
have a field day if you were alive and
what did he say if I can control your
language I can control your reality yeah
and that's right they jump onto a gender
affirming they jump onto choice they
jump on to queer they jump onto gay they
they take words and they
[Music]
that's right Tien says the Chicago
gifts for immigrants include AK-47s oh
man honestly it wouldn't be all that
shocking I'm sure there's some kind of I
think we actually can't afford not to do
that I think it's inhumane how can we as
a country say we're living up to our
founding ideals if we don't do that
didn't we give them to Ukraine oh yeah
we're running out of all kinds of things
yeah yeah that's true yeah I I just I
don't understand I also feel like I
could do better talking to people who
have
strong Arguments for immigration because
more and more and maybe this is just the
spirit that I'm living in but people who
I think it was moderate even lean
slightly Progressive are much more open
to restricting immigration than I feel
like they ever were in my lifetime you
know and I think that to tell you how
bad it's getting oh wow we have uh from
Jason Hutchinson taxation is theft
Hunter Biden is and then he compliments
him here I'm not going to read it out
loud because I'm not ever going to have
a compliment to Hunter Biden come out of
my mouth so that it can be clipped as if
I'm complimenting Hunter Biden but like
the words the next words he said you go
ahead I'll say hunter Biden is
pretty based that's horrible yeah that
word means the Dignity of that word
needs to be respected
what about that what about him his base
because taxation is stuffed so he was
paying his taxes that's what they're
saying I think that's sickening I think
that's sickening yeah it's pretty base
to not have to be subject to it exactly
it's pretty based it's pretty yeah it's
pretty base to not do what the peons
have to do yeah when your dad is a
career politician and the president it's
it's pretty based to abuse that
privilege so I'm gonna work right let's
do I'm gonna read this next Super Chat
just to let people know that I do give
voice to opposing opinion and if people
say things that are incorrect I'm
willing to hear them out so Sabi vet
says first first Super Chat for shimcast
I'm loving shimcast but I'm still amazed
Tim would leave a spoon thief in charge
give the people what they want
oh what I can't read this next part read
it I can't somebody you'd love it give
up
brimcast also your name looks like cmus
she must I I don't listen this is wow
the people have spoken and they want
brimcast firstly interesting firstly
firstly one person spoke one person
spoke and this is exactly why we were
having a conversation on the issues with
democracy I'm the Monarch here
turn your chair around I will not I just
want you to turn that chair around nope
when Tim gets back here and everybody on
a poll search yeah no but we we could do
a poll we could do a poll about that if
I decide that I'm interested in in
entertaining such absurd questions we
will
uh we've been taken over by a
dictatorship I I'm concerned about it no
I mean I would be happy to he did
actually he said well I'm gone you're in
charge and he said to me I don't believe
all that those are his words he said I
think you were just the one supposed to
sit in that chair I will give it he is
balancing so much right now he runs his
own business Freedom Tunes which is
great and also had that YouTube minute
there but they're back
um so I I as much as I obviously would
personally support and advocate for a
brimcast I think we should give Sheamus
a lot of credit because thank you he is
uh he's accomplished a lot this week
thank you that's true that's true and I
want to ask you all this oh this is my
diplomatic opinion when the next
election cycle comes up do you have do
you have personal and private opinions
interesting like to see your emails so I
have a YouTube channel called Freedom
tunes that was taken down and it's back
up but we weren't able to we usually
release video every Thursday and we
weren't able to so I really want to ask
you guys to go to Freedom tunes and
subscribe please because that would help
us a lot we were hoping we'd be able to
get a boost in traffic on the video we
released since I'm hosting the show
since Tim left me in charge couldn't
happen because the channel was taken
down this week so I'm just going to ask
you guys to go check that out you know
so become members at freedomtunes.com
become members of freedomtunes.com and
you'll be supporting what I do you'll be
helping me get free of big Tech and
you'll also get an extra cartoon each
week which exists behind the paywall
how's that sound how do you like them
apples sounds like you're poaching Tim's
audience for your own benefit which does
not sound like a very nice thing to do
I'm not poaching his audience I didn't
tell them to unsubscribe from members at
timcast.com I think they should become
members at timcast.com too Hannah Claire
this is not a zero-sum game the world's
big enough for for both of us well at
least me and Tim a Shifty character we
just got to keep a Shifty characters
I would disagree your opinion means very
little to me Hannah I know at all
Alberto chiprest Alberto excuse me I'm
trying to Alberto chipper says I chatted
yesterday about Vivek as VP and hope it
didn't come off as too dismissive of him
I'm liking the guy in his message and
hope the best for him but as of now I'm
strongly supporting Trump so here's the
thing I think it's good it was really
dismissive and you really upset him no
he's fine I mean he's fine with all the
questions that get asked him but I will
say this the man isn't running a vice
presidential campaign he's not spending
vice presidential money on this this man
is running to be president you know what
I I will say this
I really enjoyed the conversation with
him and I think he went way deeper on
his answers to the questions we gave him
than any other presidential candidate
I've ever heard speak on those issues
yeah I gotta agree he really cut into
the spiritual core of of the matter and
I was very impressed and that's great
that he did it and for the length of
time he did it because most presidential
candidates and having worked on several
presidential campaigns will do their
fake Town Halls where the answer the
questions are pre and the person gets up
there and says Carter good morning my
name is they know exactly exactly who
you are and they tilt their head and
they say that's a great question I was
wondering how they knew their names
thank you for asking me that and let me
just say that and it's all it's all
scripted so to sit in this type of forum
where you get not only super chats but
you get each other all of you that's
hard and that's why candidates don't do
it and I I keep advocating for this my
last little plug that I uh that I think
is so important before the days of covid
our politicians especially our Congress
men and women used to do that that in
their districts during the summer and
then covet happened they were like we
can't have Town Halls because and then
no one has brought that back because no
one who runs for congress wants to stand
in the high school gym and say Carter
what's your question you know like look
what's your question what no they don't
want to listen because so they they hide
behind the covet and they're not
bringing it back the best thing you can
do to get involved with democracy at the
local level is force your politicians to
stand there with a microphone in the gym
and answer every damn question and you
will see whether or not they are worthy
of the job amen amen yeah completely
agreed we have from Fisher Kingston
Daniel so you that's right are you ready
for this oh boy prepared do you want to
get your phone out Google it you just
it's gonna be a real tough one now
they're asking you Daniel so you support
nuclear reactors I think they meant do
but the question still stands of course
I love nuclear power okay yeah nuclear
power works you love nutrition okay yeah
I I you know we should have more I'm
fascinated in the the growth of of uh
micronuclear reactors
um I think we should have as many of
them as possible
um I love nuclear reactors because they
also require an awful lot of fossil
fuels and I love fossil fuels can I ask
a question I think I probably asked you
this last time around but how did you
get interested in the energy industry I
hated the lies of the environmental left
so to uh to take on their lies I had to
learn
um this issue and I hated the damage the
environment the left was doing just the
way the the coveted people the damage
they did to
14 year old girls committing suicide at
what was it 10 times the average rate
you know and the Damage that we do to
people for an agenda I that's what got
me involved in it because the damage
they do to Rural America West Virginia
coal towns are are not very far from
here and when you see the state of what
we've done to those communities and the
poverty we've left them in it made me
very very angry and I try not to be an
angry person you talked about anger
before yeah but but there is a righteous
anger yep Jesus made a a whip out of
cords and and Drew and you know kick
them out of the temple and sometimes I
think we need that enough yeah no look I
agree righteous indignation is important
you are definitely mild-mannered I
haven't seen you and by mild mannered I
don't mean like
like you speak your opinion but you you
don't get angry with people when they
challenge you I've noticed and I'll also
say righteous indignation is very
valuable and an important point about
that about you know Jesus driving the
bankers out of the temple is you can do
that you can yell at people if you're
also willing to die for them that's
another part of the story people forget
you got to be on that level
um cheers and also depending on the
circumstance you can't just Chase anyone
out everywhere okay but uh cheers to
Daniel and Rick whitback of oh I'm sorry
I'm sorry mine Pebble uh says cheers I
thinks uh cheers to Daniel and Rick
whitback of PTF out of the future nice
I've seen excuse me I've seen the drive
in both of you thank you for the voice
you lend to responsible resource
development
if it hasn't been grown then it must
have been mined yes Pebble mine is the
largest copper deposit in the world we
need a boatload of copper if we're going
to go green your average electric
vehicle has 70 to 90 pounds of copper in
it and so Market forces would dictate
that we need to mine more copper but yet
the same environmental movement that
says we have to go green says you can't
open Pebble mine it's bad for the
environment and so we get our Copper
from third world countries mined by
slaves yeah I was just going to ask you
that aren't aren't uh the components
needed for these car batteries mined by
child slaves absolutely around the world
and all of those components could be
mined responsibly in America we have
almost all the raw materials we need if
we were allowed to mine them but yet the
same forces that say you have to have
this green agenda say oh you can't open
these mine it's bad for the climate so
why are we favoring mining there's a
reason why Nike makes their their
sneakers in China right there's the same
reason why we want to get our Cobalt not
from Minnesota but we want to get it
from the Congo heck of a lot cheaper and
it shows the true pernicious nature of
this movement well and I think this is
so interesting because it's the same
people who are saying you know we have
to have higher standards we need to not
allow child labor but they won't demand
that manufacturing jobs come back to the
U.S where we could oversee this right I
mean it's complete hypocrisy good union
jobs union jobs no no not not for them
as long as they get their stuff cheap
and they don't have to think about how
what's happening to children and they
can just say that conservatives are
being mean to uh transgender identifying
minors here and they don't have to think
about the lives that go into the cheap
products they buy from Target then then
it doesn't matter to them there's
complete hypocrisy if you really believe
in protecting children you would bring
back manufacturing jobs well you know
it's also interesting because I
mentioned earlier that what the left
will do is they'll say this this really
horrible objectively evil thing is
something people are going to do anyway
so we just have to let it happen so we
can do it responsibly or have it done
responsibly and then what always happens
is more people do it and they're always
wrong but the one argument or the one
area where you actually can make that
argument is when it is something that
like isn't objectively evil so with
mining for example which is not
objectively evil like there are evil
ways of doing it and people are doing it
in evil ways and we're just letting them
do it that way instead of doing it
ourselves and driving them out of the
market like that is actually one
instance where us doing something could
prevent people from doing it in an
irresponsible Way by reducing market
demand for what they're doing uh and we
refuse yeah I'm crazy yeah
um Kyle flower says I have a friend that
used to work for Democratic campaigns he
brags about how he was able to write off
pot as a campaign expense well you need
anesthesia don't you to be working for
Democratic campaign not that I endorse
that particular method how sick how sick
all right do we have oh oh sorry did you
guys want to comment on that Anna Claire
usually has something to say
I'm not allowed to speak right now I'm
getting evil eyes from famous goodness
thank goodness she's gotten the memo
Jason Hutchinson someone just asked me
to be did you I thought you couldn't
speak I thought you couldn't speak are
you gonna make your mind up a lot of
hostility here Jason Hutchinson says
eventually you run out of room on the
balance sheet for BS in reality returns
yeah yeah true yeah I think that the
truth yeah
man
we'll go with one more here before we
sign out I'm not going to read that now
dude come on that's nonsense come on
it's nonsense I'm trying to pick the
best ones guys it's hard it's hard to
work with this guy also because Sheamus
is a tyrant is really what I'm only
reading the positive ones yeah he's
screening all the anti-spoon gate or the
the spoon gate ones well I can't allow
misinformation to fly onto his podcast
while he's gone I respect that that's a
standard to have yeah thanks you should
censor the the misinformation ones on
that's what I'm saying we should fact
check them let's get a tag on YouTube Oh
wait we're gonna do that this week
um that was a good one everyone you were
wrong about that so we'll pick the one
that was good over there too dude you
literally all right okay boom
um Wait no that's the wrong one dude I
found a good one and then you stole and
then you you scrolled and now I can't
find it anymore this is unbelievable
it's unbelievable
um Carter how are you doing yeah
someone someone had said and I want to
give them credit I wanted to give them
credit but they were basically saying
that I didn't do anything wrong and you
you know
so the evidence the evidence was was
withheld and the evidence was withheld
in my case is is all I'm saying seems
like you're looking for the the positive
escope no I saw one and someone whipped
it away from me
um someone here's actually a good
someone right yeah you did bro
um you literally did well maybe we could
just let this one go because it seems
now I really want to know what it was
yeah they literally just said that um
Sheamus didn't steal the spoons he stole
potatoes which was slander they said
potatoes but now we'll never be able to
find and credit that person is that a
mean Irish joke yeah it's another it's
another one of these horribly offensive
Justice jokes thank you racist jokes
have no place in this in this thank you
thank you and you know what I'll say
this I will say this though the fact
that they made that joke means that
they're racist against me and in spite
of their racism they were still willing
to acknowledge that I had done nothing
wrong Doug blask says where are me Lucky
Charms someone
yeah I know Doug black said Doug black
I know why he's doing this I know why
he's doing this so I'm just gonna give
him what he wants because I'm a good
host
Doug blask says where are me Lucky
Charms he wants a clip of that he wants
a clip of he's saying
yeah I'm a nice I'm a really nice guy
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
that's about all we have time for
tonight please become members at
timcast.com so you can join us in the
members only segment which is going to
start in about 10 minutes uh Daniel
thank you for joining us always a good
time Daniel Turner power of the future
power of the future.com Daniel Turner
PTF on all platforms and if you like
sheep and you want to follow a great
sheep farm here in Virginia Bristol Farm
Virginia the premier sheep farm of
Virginia I like to call it the premier
sheep farmer Virginia good good lamb and
sheep photos you'll get a kick out of it
I know it's fact check too right so why
not yeah exactly yeah I declared it this
so thanks for having me I'm so glad you
were here uh I'm Hannah Cliff brimo I'm
a writer for timcast.com you should go
to timclass.com click on the recap and
see all the work from me Chris Bertman
Adrian Norman Oliver great journalists
uh our executive editor Chris Clark I
really want to name everyone but it's
hard sometimes uh you should also 100
follow at timcast news on Twitter and
Instagram it's the best if you want to
follow me personally you can find me on
Twitter at hcbrow or on Instagram
handclare.b thank you guys so much
thank you Hannah clear for inviting me
on in place of Ian tonight thanks Daniel
for coming out no I just lied he just
showed up I never questioned your story
actually you know what no one invited me
we made it you put on a hat and jacket
exactly they did make me put a hat on
um my hair looked great and uh I could
tell that Sheamus didn't like it and
Hannah clear was like you should
probably put a hat on anyway you asked
me if you should put a hat on yeah
misinformation runs wild um so you're
Carter Banks to do all the music stuff
uh for Tim cast Tim cast music you can
follow Tim's songs at timcast songs on
YouTube Follow trash House Records on
YouTube we got a bunch of stuff coming
out yeah um including a music video that
Ian is getting in shape for right now
that's right you can follow me at Carter
banks4l on Instagram where I post
pictures of my cat that my mom sends me
Carter Banks or Twitter
um sir that's great uh yeah it's true I
wait for your cats
yeah yeah they're good um I am
search.com I'm trying to keep the show
on the rails you're doing good job shame
missions okay one more day you got this
buddy follow me on Twitter
tomorrow I'm hosting culture War live at
10 A.M because Tim is you know filming
his foot feature-length film about his
life in a as a skateboarder uh please
join me I think it'll be a great show we
have Mike Lindell and Matt Brainerd on
to talk about election stuff and
election security issues uh I'm excited
to host and I I hope you guys are there
in the morning with us although it's a
long night for everyone here Tim is
actually off chasing down the love of
his life who's going to the airport so
he can tell her how he feels right now
that's why he missed the show my name's
Seamus Coughlin I run a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we make cartoons we
got locked out of our channel for a week
and we're finally back in
um so I want to ask you guys to go over
there and subscribe to Freedom Tunes if
you like what I have to say I also have
a podcast called shamer I'm not going to
be on Tim cast next week after this so
if you like hearing what I have to say
go check my podcast out it's on Rumble
rumble.comer thank you all so much for
tuning in and we will see you on the
after show